Dover's white cliffs full of color a Sky
News beamed goodbye to the 27 EU nations
in their own language
while Downing Street also put on a light
show and here's what happened in
Parliament Square
[Applause]
brexit ears savored the moment it has
been a three and a half years and I just
feel so jubilant
I feel so sovereign again it's brilliant
[Music]
and of course one man was center stage
at the party and there are some that say
we shouldn't celebrate tonight
well we are gonna celebrate tonight this
is the single most important moment in
the modern history of our great nation
but then there's the other view in
Brighton a vigil for these remain as EU
departure is a tragic moment in our
history I feel I've had my European
that's taken away from me by this
government it's been like a grieving
process in a televised statement Boris
Johnson acknowledged the country's mixed
feelings many people this is an
astonishing moment of hope a moment they
thought would never come and there are
many of course who feel a sense of
anxiety and loss and then there's a
third group perhaps the beast who had
started to worry that the whole
political wrangle would never come to an
end
I understand all those feelings and our
job as the government my job is to bring
this country together now and take us
for leads was 50/50 in a referendum that
division is represented in the
marketplace fishmonger cautiously
optimistic for his trade I personally
would like them to look for a fair deal
with equality between Britain and the
European Union and that that be helpful
for everyone but the independent cafe
owner is finding it harder to stomach 40
percent of all the UK's fruit and
vegetables come from the EU and so I'm a
little bit worried about how that's
going to impact us and like the food
that we're able to serve so if it's
gonna have to be cabbage and potatoes
for the next six months and slow beers
well for exit menu brexit menu exactly
yeah Oh Joe has got his way
now but we don't want to go
singer and a nightingale voted remain
but was booked to perform an Aleve party
in Buckinghamshire she's got a roll with
it attitude it's part of history and
there's so many people that's so
negative about it let's get something
positive out of it so why not the excuse
to have a party but Westminster was the
place for brexit ears to party was
decided when Boris Johnson won the
general election and there's a feeling a
little bit like the end of a civil war
where everyone just wants to lay down
their weapons and go home for a rest the
victors have been decided but divisions
will still take time to heal and
opinions will still differ on whether
Britain is now standing tall or looking
precarious Jason Farrell Sky News